do you know that Darin wrote his first
notes on Evolution and sent it out to
other scientists for comment in
1844 mhm I just found that very
fascinating and interesting because
that's the same year in which
spiritualism started in the world with a
rapping in of the fox sisters so you
have
spiritualism very intricately involved
in daismachine
himself belonged to an organization that
is called the ghostly Guild where they
would communicate with Spirit entities
and where they had uh phenomena taking
place like tables rising from the from
the floor and this is all well
documented in the
literature welcome back to LED live
everybody we have a a awesome special
guest today I know I say that every
single time but today is an awesome
special guest I'm very excited Walter VI
thank you for coming by on our show it's
a pleasure if you guys don't know who
this guy is and his ministry we're going
to put some links in the description
below you will be blessed by the amazing
information that you guys have put out
and we're going to get into a topic that
we haven't actually covered very much
before have we actually talked about
Evolution at all not that I remember no
yeah and so why is evolution important
in especially this day and age right now
I think we're going to kind of get into
this topic and and talk about that but
welcome to the show thank you very much
we're excited to have you on we watch
your channel from from time to time and
and been blessed by the ministry that
you and Martin have been doing um love
the current event stuff I think it's
really important to pay attention you
know pick our eyes up and look around
and and that's what I really appreciate
about the work you guys are doing
um but you were a professor tell us a
little bit about your expertise in this
area and why you're even able to speak
expressedly on this topic well I was a
professor in Zoology but my speciality
was animal physiology comparative animal
physiology so that gives you a pretty
broad spectrum and you can move into
animal experimentation that even links
on to the medical world so I also I'm a
professor in medical
bioscience so I sort of sat on two
chairs my research was largely medical
using animals as a model but my
background is
zoology and as such of course I was an
evolutionist and an atheist like every
good zoologist should be which is crazy
you're looking at the beautiful creation
this amazing complex world that we live
in and disregarding the maker that's
crazy there was no maker Evolution
doesn't allow for a Divine foot in the
door yeah there is no Creator so whether
you you speak to the guys at Oxford or
at Cambridge or any one of them there is
no room for a deity in any of this
everything has to be explained
naturalistically and yet each of them
would go to court if anyone tried to put
their name on their body of work you
know they want the credit when it comes
to research or anything that they
created but no no no credit to what
they're observing yes now if you take
people like uh Richard Dawkins for
example he's a very outspoken
evolutionist he is uh against God in
every sense of the word but he
identifies as a cultural Christian
interesting so that's very interesting
so I found that fascinating but uh he
wrote a book called The God Delusion
yeah in which he uses every adjective
derogatory adjective in the in the
dictionary to describe God but his
concept comes not from the Bible his
concept comes from religious teachings
which are contrary to the Bible while
supposedly embracing the Bible often you
see the rejection French Revolution
right what are they rejecting they're
rejecting a type of
Christianity and rightfully so I mean it
was pretty Twisted in back then so you
know you I think we're all respons
responsible but you can kind of then
begin to understand if that's his
starting block of what he's judging off
of yes yeah I remember being in school
and of course we got a lot of evolution
because I was a science major and you
know had to read papers by Steven Gould
and and people like that and most I
would say most of my professors were
professed Christians they went to the
Methodist Church or or whatever and um I
remember sitting in one class I think it
was biokm 2 and they were having a
discussion I I usually just listened a
lot and one lady she said you know she
was talking about being a Christian but
but how she found Evolution there was so
much overwhelming evidence that it was
just undeniable and I was like Wow to
think that you have gone to that point
and I always had a hard time like how
are you living with yourself you know
sitting in both worlds but you know in
in in science and this is one thing I
try to clarify for people
is when and you'd be able to speak to
this but when they talk about Evolution
being a theory the word theory is used
differently in science than it is in the
general uh
vocabulary we use the term Theory kind
of loosely like oh it's just a theory
like it's some you know yeah not really
like it doesn't hold a lot of weight in
science theory holds a lot more weight
than uh than it would in just you know
everyday vocabulary and so for them
theory is right before something becomes
a law but fascinating Evolution has
never become a law why because there's
never been enough evidence to consider
it to be a law in science like gravity
it's past the point of hypothesis it's
come to the point of theory yeah but you
must understand the mindset there is no
God yeah yeah so somewhere along the
line something had to come into
existence and the only plausible theory
that we have is the theory of evolution
so even if it fails on certain points
you have to prop it up with pillars in
other places in order to make it stand
because the alternative God is just too
ghastly to contemplate yeah well this
coming into our world's existence in the
late 1800s right Charles Darwin came up
with this kind of a concept and um if he
was really truly tutored by the devil
right there must be a really good reason
why that's brought out in the end of the
world yes well why would you want to
negate the Book of Genesis because the
Genesis Book tells you about the
beginnings number one and it tells you
about the reasons for the state of the
world what happened in the beginning the
loss of certain privileges that were
associated with creation and then you
have the Book of Revelation which is the
antithesis to the book of of Genesis
everything that is lost in the Book of
Genesis access to the Tree of Life
immortality uh access
to Eden let's say Celestial City all of
these issues they are restored in the
Book of Revelation now why would you
have a book of restoration of things
that never happened in the first place
good point exactly that's a really good
point so if you if you take the two
bookends and you negate them if you
negate the first sentence in the
beginning God then you also negate the
sentence in the end God oh interesting
well that's how that's from from a
jewish's mind that's how they wrote
right didn't they have kind of writing
with bookends on the middle and they
sort of tell you the the the whole story
in the beginning and then sort of ended
up with the whole story pointing back to
that point yeah the whole Bible is
actually a chastic structure yeah yeah
the crazy thing is we're completely okay
with things being different in between
like we call that normal but it's not
normal all the things in Genesis that
God started and then all the things in
Revelation that God restores that's the
way it's supposed to be but in the
middle it's not the way it's supposed to
be but we think it's normal yeah well
people stick to the middle because they
need hope yeah now when I was an atheist
we used to embrace the religious people
coming to our University and presenting
creationist ideas because we had great
sport taking it apart afterwards and
ridiculing it yeah and uh in that way we
were very successful in changing the
minds of students I mean we live in a
very conservative country I come from
South Africa and most people are
religious when they come to the
university and within 3 years we drive
that out of them there was a statistical
study of of how this is actually
achieved and how the mindsets are
switched and they have Christian
organizations working at the University
campus with students to convince them
that evolution is correct oh wow and
that they have to adopt a theistic
Evolution hypothesis in order to fit
into the world otherwise you will be
contrary to what is good
science so the aim even of Christian
organizations often is to divert the
Mind away from what scripture says to
what is a compromise between scripture
and human thinking yeah if you break the
confidence right in the beginning this
is this is just a fallible you know
madeup story or whatever like that I
mean the the the main religious entity I
saw a video clip of the Pope one time
that was saying like you know he
believed in the myth or or believed that
creation was a myth and I was like the
guy who's touting or the world is
touting as the guy who should be the
religious voice in the world doesn't
even believe that creation is real The
Big Bang Theory is an is a Jesuit
concept interesting yeah wow so before
we get into this I just have this weird
question you don't have to answer that
but um are they blending humans and
animals are they blending them now yeah
genetically absolutely yeah I saw a
video where they were legislating it on
a legislative lesson level and I was
like if they're legislating for that
that means they've already done it and
they were like talking about you can't
make more than 50% man and 50% animal
and I was like
wow okay we don't have to get into that
unless you want a show about that let us
know in the comment section below but
the floor is yours teach us well why was
I an evolutionist in in the first
place same as Richard Dawkins because of
theolog iCal Concepts that are placed
into the minds of young people my mother
was a Lutheran my father was a Roman
Catholic and the two religions before
the 60s were on opposite sides of the
pole and I was taught that my mother who
was very sick was going to go straight
to hell because she didn't have the
right
religion so I was about 10 years or so
old at this at the time and so I
rebelled against this God in natural
fact I should have rebelled against the
teaching and not rebell against the god
of the teaching but uh I rebelled
against that and so I would consider
myself from probably the age of 10 or 11
as an atheist not believing in God
because you just if there was a God
you're mad I don't want that God so he
doesn't exist as far as I'm concerned
and if he does exist he can get lost
right uh that was basically how I grew
up when I got to University I came into
contact with Evolution Theory I went
very deep into it and I taught Evolution
at the tertiary level at University did
you recognize the inconsistencies then
no you would rationalize the
inconsistencies they were there for
example uh the the whole question of
intermediary fossils MH not being there
you mentioned Steven J Gould earlier in
the
conversation now Steph J G came up with
a theory called punctuated equilibrium
you always give a fancy name to
something yeah you want it to sound
smart yeah so so that it sounds good now
what the heck is punctuated
equilibrium basically punctuated
equilibrium was invented because of the
lack of inter mediary fossils Darin said
that if intermediary fossils didn't
exist it was a good argument against his
theory and they don't exist that's the
problem if they did exist they wouldn't
need punctuated equilibrium so what is
punctuated equilibrium punctuated
equilibrium is the
idea that uh there is no gradual
Evolution that's visible in the fossil
record so there was a long period per of
stability so everything looks the same
and then punctuated instantly you had
because of some environmental
circumstance or something very rapid
change MH and then back to equilibrium
where nothing changes so when you look
at the fossil record you don't see any
change you just see okay here are
creatures but they're fully formed how
did they get there well it was so rapid
that the the intermediaries got lost in
the process
so so I went from a fish to a bird
immediately well not quite to the fish
to the bird but let's say from the fish
to the amphibian oh Goa got and from the
amphibian to the reptile and from the
reptile to the bird and from the reptile
to the mammal Etc now being a
comparative physiologist of course you
also look at not only the anatomy of
these creatures but you look at the
physiology of these creatures MH and uh
the Anatomy often dictates the
physiology mhm and you can't just change
the anatomy without changing the
physiology so it gets very tricky
because uh there are whole enzyme
structures whole genetic um sequences
that have to change when you change an
anatomical sequence you also have to
change the metabolic sequence for
example how do you go from a a cold
blooded creature to a warm-blooded
creature without changing the metabolism
right all of these things must um sort
of develop simultaneously and it's very
very complex but that's all you have so
let's say you start off as a gradualist
that's Darin ISM gradual change over
long periods of time that's called the
gradualist and then you don't find the
change happening in the fossil record so
you are compelled to become a pun uated
equilibrium which is a Ste Steven J G
follower and you have these two schools
of thought and they're always at
loggerheads with each other but you
really have no no option you have to go
that route mhm and they don't know they
can identify what's causing the
punctuation they just know it's happen
or they believe it's happening or
they'll say there was a rapid
environmental change global warming
could do it you know what I mean I see I
see you know I I did these things come
up Christianity in the conversation and
does the whole group just be like no no
no no be quiet we're not going to even
and then why discredit things like the
flood you know that punctuated event
we'll talk about everything like with
the planet was seated by animal or
aliens and all sorts of stuff like this
like we'll entertain some pretty wild
things but not Christianity no leave
that off the table oh they actually do
entertain alien but not in the sense of
alien beings although the metaphysical
world will go there and say that alien
beings interfered in the the evolution
of humanity they made the punctual
something a machine let's leave that up
they will have a theory that if it
didn't happen here because it couldn't
happened here it must have happened
elsewhere and that theory is called pans
spermia interesting pans spermia so it
was spermed from out of space so you
can't get a molecule to form
naturalistically so it must have
happened out of space whether with
different conditions you don't exactly
know how you can't prove it and I came
here via meteor and boom then they were
there and they could be incorporated
that's how it works yeah that's the
irritating part there's a lot of stuff
that can't be proven which science is
supposed to be about proving
duplicatable experimentation right and
so much of this is not yes so you have
to have these prop theories in order to
explain what's inexplicable and here's
what's crazy is it's like you know
they're so not willing to just say hey
look the Christianity to me makes a lot
of sense when you listen to it at
least everybody needs to be honest and
come to the point and say that they're
both approaching their worldview by
faith yeah yeah well I came to that
conclusion because when I was eventually
confronted with certain things in the
scriptures which were irrefutable cuz
there are things in scripture which are
irrefutable give an example
Daniel prophecy yeah prophecy Daniel
Daniel chapter 2 Daniel chapter 7 Daniel
chapter 8 Daniel chapter 9 you mention
the civilizations you there's no way
around that there is no way you can you
can say it must have been written after
the fact but archaeology disproves that
scroll So eventually you get to the
point all right this is
irrefutable now is that the only thing
that's irrefutable or you know how
irrefutable is the rest of the story
then does a dove tell in so my first
confrontation I would say was
prophecy which I really tried to negate
I went to every Library Under the Sun to
the theological schools I really tried
to prove that this was written after the
fact or whatever and came up against the
brick wall this is you're bringing up a
really good point a lot of people like
to throw things out and not do the
investigation go look it up like like
you You' got such a hard stance about
this or that and You' never looked at
the
information yeah and I'm I'm curious
why why why did you not want to
change well I had such a terrible
concept of God that God didn't exist I
mean I was confronted as a as a lecturer
when I was giving lectures at uh the
university even at first year level and
sometimes at postgraduate level by
students that were religious I would
blast them off the planet because that
is such a ridiculous notion how can how
dare you confront this God called
science so you were kind of like
verbally antagonistic towards them like
militantly did you ever have a Christian
hold his own weight and you like walked
away from the conversation going he had
some good arguments well did you ever
feel like that that one of them actually
brought about a change in me wow oh wow
and that was a young girl in a first
year medical class I was giving a
lecture on the evolution of the kidney
and I went right from the beginning all
the way through and she put up her hand
3/4 way through and said I don't believe
a word you're saying I love it and I
said excuse
me and uh then she said she believed in
creation and she believed God created it
and of course I I blasted of the planet
and
eventually ridiculed her as well did she
cry and she cried yes because the class
enjoyed it oh I bet and so they started
mocking her too but many many years
later uh I actually found out who it was
so yes that's in retrospect but that
actually started something in me because
when I got back to my office for the
first 10 minutes I felt pretty pleased
with myself for having annihilated her
so I thought but uh 15 20 minutes later
I felt guilty for having done it in the
way that I had done it and uh once you
start feeling guilty you want some kind
of relief from that guilt and that
started the religious process in me
where do you find relief from a guilt
that you have so listen up students
lesson learned right here if you were
the voice of change you might not think
you had an influence you might not think
like you standing up for what you
believe in is even going to make a
difference or whatsoever people make fun
of you you might have had a bad
experience in a classroom like this but
look at the result of of this you
changed somebody's mind the second one
was even more dramatic I only had two of
those really important experience I had
lots of discussions because we'd have
creationists come to the university and
give a lecture and then in the classes
we would rip them apart and the students
would ask questions and we would answer
them scientifically and and tear apart
whatever these people had
said uh but then when I started my own
journey I started developing some
questions and at one stage the we had a
a discussion group where the staff of
the University of the zoology department
and the postgrad students would come
together to discuss issues
surrounding
Evolution and I had to I regularly LED
these sessions because everybody got a
turn to lead them and it was my turn and
I thought to myself okay I'm going to
put some of these questions on the
board and that's all I did I put some
questions on the board and the result
was absolute pandemonium oh wow I never
expected that I I expected some
discussion from the question but I
didn't get that I got Fury oh wow oh wow
Fury anger such as you cannot believe
people literally farming at the mouth
with anger like evolutionist minded
people yes all we were all evolutionists
we were basically all atheists although
some people as you said actually went to
church and were even Elders in church
but they were evolutionary atheists I
don't know how that works but that's how
it worked and uh after that anger
Outburst a young student also a young
lady got up and she said when I came to
this University I believed in God and in
creation and I was very happy in my
faith and you have turned me into
atheist and now I realize that I've been
lied to oh wow and that caused even more
pandemonium oh wow so that if they could
have slaughtered me they would have and
it actually got to the point where I had
to
resign not because I was forced to
resign but because I couldn't live in
that circumstance anymore and I left
that University and then I joined
another University later where I became
the professor of zoology by the way I
was probably the only professor at a
secular University in the southern
hemisphere that believed in creation wow
well praise God that there was one yeah
you that they appointed me is even a
miracle wow you you made a comment how
can someone be a Christian even as far
as being an elder in their church yet
believe in evolution and I remember that
being my experience growing up in middle
school high school I thought reading as
I'm reading through the creation account
God spoke and then we had the creation
week but I thought every day was like a
millennia so embedded within God
creating it just took a while for each
thing to grow and for the water to rise
up and so that's how I rationalized the
two ideas it was only till later that I
realized that I was taught that even
believing that even blending those two
ideas is still anti the Bible anti who
God is because God speaks and things
happen you know it's questioning the
authority and power of God to blend the
two they don't mix these two ideologies
cannot mix they actually negate each
other yes that's true and the spirit
behind the evolution evolutionary
mindset as you were talking about the
rage and the not wanting to delve into
the information to see to to dig deeper
and to see why there are these
inconsistencies and actually finding the
answers that the Bible displays it's
that spirit that we know who it comes
from yeah cuz isn't that the scientific
way you have a problem you lay out all
the things on the table and you try to
find out the problem you test all the
different Avenues because you want to
make sure that the one that you're going
with is the right you know most tried
and true tested thing wouldn't you want
to test them all yeah I I wondered
though in that how big of a community
that may be where there are
evolutionists who
still have a level of respect for things
different things within the Bible they
may not take the whole Bible take
Christianity altogether but they would
respect prophecies or like different
aspects of it is that the case or it's a
Hardline complete evolutionist and then
Christian no you get a category of
people that are called theistic
evolutionists they blend the two
concepts and as you say those are just
very long periods of time you have a
problem because Evolution requires death
as the driving force to create change so
you have survival of the
fittest and the one that goes extinct
makes room for the one that has the
genes to propagate the Next Generation
and therefore death is a very essential
part of the driving force for The
evolutionary process whereas in the
scripture death is a consequence of sin
there was no death before yeah so if
death is the driving force to bring
about a superior being like
Humanity then why the story about death
being a consequence of sin and if so why
would you need a savior yeah if he if
God used death as the driving force to
create Humanity over a long period of
time theistic evolutionary thinking then
why would he have to send his son to die
for a process that he used in the first
place throws out the most important
things so it throws out not only the
process but it throws out the Aton
because it negates the atonement the
atonement is not necessary for something
that is naturalistically necessary for a
creation I think I remember seeing a
Stephen Hawkins not maybe it Steven
Hawkins um Richard Dawkins um video clip
where he was like I hope there's not a
God I think I've seen this clip before
and just like yeah of course you have
that perspective because you know all
that you've said and done against this
this entity you're just like I actually
hope that this is not real so that you
know I don't have to change or yeah just
the consequences yeah now you're going
to be held reliable for all these things
you know and I think that's at the heart
of this thing is like you now have to be
confronted with well how am I living I
would like to have a talk with him if
that were possible because you ever
tried no I haven't actually tried
although I was actually you know
involved in many of those universities
through my postgraduate student Exchange
programs but the the point is their
concept of God is so wrong mhm they have
this wful deity in mind that can have no
other thought than to obliterate you for
anything that you've done that is
wrong and uh therefore they cannot they
cannot align the god of the Old
Testament with the god of the New
Testament so the one is to them an
insipid
wishy-washy forgive everybody God and
the other one is a wrathful deity that
wants to clobber you over the head but
the Bible says that they're one and the
same so how do you reconcile those
Concepts and because you can't you throw
them both out like the baby with a B
water MH yeah I remember thinking how
how Evolution was very selfish you know
that's it's all about self-preservation
right so the only way you're propagating
your own gene pool is is due to
selfishness you want to survive you want
your own to survive and so it's void of
Love though I've seen some articles that
try to massage that a bit like well the
reason you have emotions is that you can
care about your Offspring and and so
that you can propagate your Gene pole
but still it's not not the same as you
love them because you just love them and
care about them it it doesn't exist very
well in that ecosystem it's all very
self-driven mhm yeah and then how are
you ever going to be is so opposite the
others focused you know the whole Bible
is really about loving you know God with
all your heart and doing what he says
and then also you know loving your
fellow man it's like survival the
fittest is just literally like I got to
get mine before you got to get yours
that's the me mentality and it works its
way into Hollywood you know some of the
things that we talk about you look at
the poster for X-Men apocalypse it says
Only the Strong will survive at the top
that's Evolution right there yeah yeah
that's how is actually affecting our pop
culture today and not only affects that
it affects everything it affects our
medical world for example because if
everything is evolutionary then
everything is
interconnected that means that uh DNA
happened by chance which gives you the
right to manipulate it as you want toh
whereas if you were created in the image
of God then your DNA is
pretty kind
orientated and uh the thinking pattern
behind
behind it gives you the right to do
certain things which otherwise would be
considered highly unethical which is
where they are wanting this to go I know
this conversation is not necessarily
about transhuman or where they're
actually pushing this thing but yes you
disregard God in that equation and it's
like why why couldn't you edit your
genes why couldn't you GMO people why
could why can't why can't we improve
upon them that's right why couldn't you
add the the technology into the body
that would you know allow you to live
forever with no consequences you said
you didn't want to go there but I I have
a question and excuse my my ignorance
but I'm wondering how much truth is is
within Evolution as Sin entered into the
world because can a human set something
in motion so to speak where the concept
of evolution plays out when we read in
the Bible the story with um uh the anti-
delians at the Tower of Babel God put a
stop to it because of what they were
capable of so so does evolution have its
place in the sinful world and it didn't
have its place during uh the what God
created and what God is seeking to
restore well it gets rather complicated
when you when you think about all of
those genetic implications I mean why is
there genetic degeneration in the first
place mhm does there have to be genetic
degeneration why is it for example that
generative cells like uh OVA or sperm
cells have the capacity to remain in a
juvenile
form uh even if the rest of the cells
are
aging I mean an 80-year-old man has
perfectly verile spermatazoa that can
produce perfectly verile Offspring Etc
interesting so what is the limiting
factor and and that is the research that
is going on but we're going way into
another direction we totally are but the
elixir of Life how can you restore all
of that what happened at the Tower of
Babel you were asking that you know I
think it's you know it's good that we
don't completely you know categorize
people as one way or the other I read a
book on um
crisper it was just kind of coming on
the scene when I was was graduating and
crisper is this DNA Gene editing
technique it's it's like word processing
for your
genome but um the people that were
developing it actually called for a
moratorium on it until there were
ethical um guard rails put in place and
I don't know if they were Christian I
don't know if they were evolutionists
but there was a team of scientists that
were calling for it so I'm I'm guessing
there's a team of scientists there's
probably some evolutionists there
and still calling for that moratorium
because they saw you know the
implications even not being Christians
they you know likely saw the
implications that hey we shouldn't just
Tinker with this to no end or or open
the box somebody did in China there was
um a scientist who did he edited um The
genome for um these two twin girls and
made it so that they could not contract
HIV but there were consequences to that
it made them more susceptible to other
things and that's the thing it's like
you have to be careful with like you're
tinkering with a technology for lack of
a better word that you don't completely
understand when you look at the genetic
system you have a lot of well the
majority of the genes where they didn't
know what their function was they were
sort of considered as relics of the
evolutionary process you don't need that
you don't need that you don't need this
and you only use x amount of your
genetic system the rest is redundant now
that kind of thinking has slowly been
eroded over time as we realize that the
The genome is very very complex and that
uh everything is not based on structural
genes originally when you talk about
Evolution you talk about a gene a
protein and a protein is can be an
enzyme that leads to a certain process
so you have structural genes and that's
what you look like that's what you
transfer you have a lot of this
irrelevant DNA that's mixed in there but
uh most of the genome actually consists
of controlling
genes so they don't they don't actually
have an expression in the phenotype in
what you look like they only control
that which happens at that level and
that brings about a whole uh New Concept
how to control genes how do how do genes
for example um become so that they can
be read more often than previously you
can go for example in one generation
from a small rat to a giant rat just by
translocating a gene to a specific Locus
where it is red more often and produces
more growth hormone than it would
normally do and you go in one generation
from small to large or vice versa now
those would be considered evolutionary
processes that took a long time but we
know that they can take place instantly
but they're not Evolution they are built
into the genetic system to enable the
genetic system to actually bring about
rapid change within the parameters of
the of of the species right how come
they um cannot just make the missing
link if you can edit these genes and you
could do that why wouldn't evolutionists
say let's create something that would
forever seal this deal that there's some
you know because man walking around that
Missing Link never existed but I mean do
they have the technology to kind of
create that and they would have to
amalgamate and you can tell that you can
do that there's a category of animals
that doesn't exist today in the world
world it's called the mammal-like
reptiles in the fossil record you have
mammals and you have reptiles and then
you have a another category huge
category of animals called mamalik
reptiles they don't exist today not one
of them they're gone dinosaurs in that
category no dinosaurs are not in that
category dinosaurs are reptiles but you
have mammal likee reptiles which have
features of both mammals and reptiles
they don't exist do you think that was
man messing with amalgam Asians I today
I would would speculate in that
direction but you know as only the
animals that God created got on that Ark
you know as an evolution I would not but
find it
interesting that those creatures do not
exist today there's no reason why they
shouldn't be viable because they were a
huge category of animals yeah I can't
wait to get to heaven and and just I I
just it's like a secret vault you know
it's like I want to know what happened
on this planet but there are fossils to
prove that category existed is that what
you're saying
thousands and thousands of fossils of
mamalik reptiles yes wow interesting
actually to that point I have a question
uh you were part of a um a project
called the days of Noah or uh is it the
days of no it's a four-part series I got
through the first two fascinating a
chalk full of information but I noticed
they were explaining all the the proofs
that are out there towards the flood
even here in North America we have the
the Grand Canyon and all that the the
information that's there but it was kept
in the realm of animals where are the
anti delians where are the the people
who died during the flood do we have any
proof of them and where where are the
preservations of of them we have fossils
that uh don't really fit
into the Paradigm as they should there
are fossils of very large human beings
like what size uh let's say up to 3 m in
feet well it's like
9t 9t roughly that's how that's how high
um um Goliath was I think and half ft
and you have
artifacts and in the past of of
civilizations that just don't fit the
Paradigm you find Hammers and kinds of
Steel which we are not even able to
reproduce today but you are right the
vast amounts
or numbers of fossils that you would
expect are not there now why are they
not there well that's an interesting
mute point we can get into the
metaphysics there but uh the Bible says
that this world was destroyed because of
sin right mhm and where would you find
sin most prevalent there were Humanity
lived in congregation
[Music]
like sod Andor for example Valley yes so
where would you find probably the
fossils that are associated with it
there where the destruction is the
greatest mhm now where is the
destruction the greatest where's the
greatest evidence of Destruction you
mentioned the gr Canyon it's one of
those beautiful features that shows uh a
very rapid catastrophic formation of the
canyon the theories of slow formation
just don't fit in the Grand Canyon area
because you don't have Rivers cutting
through Hills They Go Round
Hills but in that case it was the case
but the greatest canyons in the world
are not on land they're under the ocean
that's right Canyons that are unex
vastly superior to what you find so you
know you have the theory of Atlantis and
the lost civilizations what if Humanity
largely
congregated and were destroyed and most
of those fossils are under the ocean
yeah deep below where you could probably
easily get to them correct and you need
then there would be a lot of uh trapped
organic material down there you know
what maybe we're driving with them today
yeah
interesting a lot of the oil fields of
course the great ones are under the
ocean now what if vast categories of
creatures now there where you had rural
areas or where populations were not
largely distributed you would find the
other animals like you would today so
those fossils we can find on land but
when we find them they are also all in
in watery Graves H now we always say in
the evolution theory that they were in
River beds and that flash floods sort of
buried these creatures or they were
ponds and the creatures came to drink
got stuck in the mud Etc that doesn't
happen today you don't get fossilization
because scavengers eat them up bacterial
rotting takes place there's no
fossilization of that nature that's
actually a really good point yeah the
only thing that really point that I've
never really even kind of considered
that before like like we don't see that
happening right now no it doesn't happen
but you find Rapid burial of anything
from a dinosaur to whales and the
interesting thing is they're often
stream
orientated so you find these creatures
lying in a in a particular direction now
that is only possible if it's
catastrophic now
99% of all fossils are in mud beds so in
other words they are water depositions
and if you still have orientation then
that is
catastrophism but uh it wasn't Universal
they will say because as soon as you
have a universal destruction Evolution
ends that's right because you have to
develop to the point of humanity if you
wipe everything out then you would have
to start the evolution process all over
again right right and you got humans
quickly science cannot allow a universal
flood listen to that breakdown in almost
every level which ties back to Evolution
yes so you only had local floods
now most of the fossils as I say are of
that nature are watery demises and you
get a couple that are let's say Vol
buried in volcanic ash but then you have
mainly molds of whatever there was
before you will find that at vvus for
example you'll find even humans uh the
burnt away so the only the casing
remains of whatever there was or you'd
have them in in
Pete or in oil or in something like that
where they are buried you find those in
Pete boogs for example those are
probably post flood finalization but
happened quickly yes but they're they're
not not very prevalent so that's the
kind of humanity that you would find you
would find something here you'd find
something there but you wouldn't find
the masses that you would expect but
they're probably under the ocean that's
why you have uh mythologies like
Atlantic
wow fascinating yeah you know and and
the the the Demonic World they
understand and know what happened and
they're you know they're taking those
stories of of like there's something
under there and if we tell enough
stories like they're probably paying
attention to prophecy going hey this is
a really great way to people to make
people believe some truth over here and
so if we start talking about it over
here then somebody finds something over
here it's going to believe it and the
idea is always you know it was primitive
then and it has to be Advanced now and
these people were stupid and we're
brilliant yeah yeah but that's not it if
you go into the archaeological world how
did they transport or even cut those
huge pillars out of the ground that were
as hard as Stone we can't do that today
You' need specialized Laser Technology
in order to do that we find artifacts
that are hard to explain we find
hieroglyphics that are hard to explain
the
technology might even have been far
Advanced to what we have today like a
printer
yes all kinds of objects they find
cathode rays they find all kinds of of
materials in the fossil record and also
technologies that we have lost that we
are not capable of that we are still
wondering about and uh a sort of hidden
archaeology yeah I got a friend of mine
that I love to talk about like you know
random things in the world and he's he's
always talking to me about like the even
even in the um world wars they were
looking for Noah's tools yes that was
interesting you mentioned um the Tower
of Babel and the Bible says God there
confused the languages right yeah now if
you just take language for example if
language were
evolutionary then you would have a
progression from simple sounds to
complex language MH but if you go
through the history of languages they're
always far more structured and complex
in the past than what they are today
interesting we've actually had to
simplify them because we've become
dumbed down we're like goldfish yeah if
you if you take Shakespeare he had a
vocabulary of 28,000 words yeah and the
average person today has about 5,000
Words which were probably exposed to
more words just from your phone and
correct and the cases that you used you
know the nominative accusative data and
all of those they were all Incorporated
in a very complex structure so that you
could very precisely describe things
also in the different cases now the King
James version still uses the thine ye
your you for a very specific reason
because without it you would not be able
to determine exactly who you are
speaking to take for example Jesus is
speaking to Nicodemus and he say says
verily verily I say unto thee that's
singular he's addressing
emus that's plural must be born again if
you take that out you lose those
connotations yeah that just that just
opens up your mind to go like I
appreciate the great the King James
version tons more just that wasn't in
the common language at the time they had
simplified it to the simple U wow which
by the way is plural wow and is not
singular but is used in a singular
fashion today what I'm saying is
language was far more structured and
complex in the past than it is now right
so is that Evolution or is that
Devolution on the level of language now
we're just like we take out all the
vowels
seriously you know it's like we don't
want to type out the thing we're
lazy wow that's amazing yes that really
is
mind-blowing I just going to sit and
chew on that yeah right you know sit and
chew on that for a second um I mean just
so much beautiful things that I think
God has preserved in in in looking at
the record of what's happened in the
planet I think that God had that
forethought things are going to go wrong
people are going to have questions put
them in the earth you know what I mean
let the Earth cover it in a way that
people will dig it up and it should
answer what happened back then otherwise
you just leave it to you humans are
going to reinterpret everything
constantly it'd be so confusing and so
God had to make a way for us to look
backwards and see the record and make
decisions about what happened it must be
very frustrating if you're trying to
negate something in the Bible and then
you dig it up in archology
yeah it take the year 457 BC the decree
for arter Sexes uh to restore and
rebuild Jerusalem unto Messiah the
prince a very precise prophecy as to
when the Messiah would be you know
inaugurated as the Messiah and that date
as a starting date is cast in stone
because it stands on an
archaeological find so it's irrefutable
you cannot move it that must be very
frustrating to the God negators yeah
well that's why I think evolution is an
important topic to discuss I'm glad that
you were you know able to come on and
talk about this topic because I think
it's irrelevant to us today I think
there's a lot of Christians that just H
you know I don't need to know about that
or whatever like that I have had a very
close friend of mine and and he raised
his children totally Christian and he
his son went to go into college
Christian his whole life took one class
one class doesn't believe in God and
it's like oh what you can derail
somebody off of like literally a
professor yes well when I started
lecturing on this issue of course I come
into conflict with all my
my
colleagues so the students would ask me
in class because whenever I spoke about
these issues I would say according to
the theory of evolution this is how it
works and students are very observant
you know that they would stop me and say
excuse me you're the only one who ever
says that all the other says this is how
it happened you say according to the
theory of evolution this is how it
happened why do you say that do you
actually not believe it or
what that's awesome uh would you give us
an answer to that question then I would
say to them you know it's not part of
the curriculum of the
university the university has a
curriculum that has to remain in the
bounds of what they're
saying so I will not tell you in this
class what my opinion is on the matter
but should you ask me to give you a
lecture
after hours then it is on our own time
and on our own premise then I could tell
you that's being wise as a serpent
harmless as a dove absolutely brilliant
that's like me going I can't tell you it
came from the Bible you know what I mean
like have you ever seen the butter
that's like this is actually not butter
brilliant it's It's Not Butter but
they're telling you it's butter by not
telling do you think do you think
there's a student in the world that
won't take up that challenge absolutely
no because now they're they're curious
what they want to know abely
and so they would arrange that and then
they would come into the other people's
classes and the guy would say or whoever
it was the lecture this and this and
this was happen they say excuse me
that's
wrong and that
created major conflict fireworks
fireworks you know that could have been
the coolest YouTube channel back then if
you had a camera in that room yeah you
know what I mean somebody needs to do
that that's so wise you know that's how
my pastor taught us students to take
tests as we were preparing for College
um because really you got to get through
it there's certain classes you just have
to take depending on your major so when
it comes to you have this test you know
the information you may not agree with
the information use language according
to so and so this is the answer and just
keep it push and get your grade and you
know keep your your stance firm in in
the Lord but Scotty to your point about
um the student who just one class and
flip them there's there's two points I'd
like to make one the reverse is also
true
the the reverse back to the Lord
instantaneous or just uh finding truth
and making the decision to stand for the
right but someone may ask man how weak
is Christianity or Christians where
they're presented with any sort of push
back and they can just give up
everything but I think that's the beauty
of Christ the beauty of who he is and
Christianity because it's choice-based
it's not this Spirit of anything that is
against what I believe I'll just throw
it out completely or like I don't even
want to hear it I'm going to U be so
visceral towards you about it the Lord
is giving us the opportunity to come let
us reason together and so you know that
student he may be on a journey I think
that's why it's so important for us as
Christians to intercede on behalf of
others and to pray and and ask the Lord
to germinate those seeds that are
planted because it could be so
insignificant in the moment but years
down the road he may come back into the
knowledge of the truth awesome yeah and
his knowing who that is his decision my
personal opinion is it's not based on
the science he based his decision on a
relationship and he's upset and he's
angry and so it's his way to to get back
at God and to get back at you know his
parent I think that's a lot of people's
experience and say I'm rejecting this
because I'm rejecting
you you know it's not not they're not
it's not about the information from
Christianity is about rejecting the
individual like it is was in your case
and you know God sees that and him being
a personal God you know he will he will
through his Divine wisdom re re
reestablish that relationship and show
him who he really is show that
individual who he really is it does say
come let us reason together right for
every argument out there on the
evolutionary level there is a
counterargument which is equally as
plausible mhm so if you actually put
them on the table and that's why you
have so many creationists today and uh
there was an argument once uh about you
know who would become a creationist in
this modern world he would have to be
insane there was this argument in
Australia and somebody put out a
challenge I forget who it was that uh
scientists with phds in their field
would never ever become creationists and
you wouldn't be able to find one so the
one guy Rose to the challenge and says
I'll find you 50 and the guy laughed
himself into a
coma and then he wrote a book why 50
scientists believe in creation and uh I
was asked to write one small portion of
that book and these were all physicists
and uh chemists and biologists and
botanists and zoologists and all of them
put together and that book came out a
couple of years ago and the reasons that
they give for becoming creationists is
not that they were struck by lightning
one day and had a conversion experience
but based on the facts which can be
interpreted in a different way so I have
a couple of lectures out there it's
called The Genesis conflict series and
there are seven lectures in that Series
where I look at everything from the
genetic level to the paleontology to
catastrophism versus uniformitarianism
and people can look at it and they can
look at the facts but you know what
facts never convince you by themselves
because wherever there's a fact somebody
will come up with an alternative what
they consider as a fact good point
you're looking at it like this I'm
looking at it like that right so what
else do you need you need something else
Holy Spirit now yes exactly you need the
Holy Spirit now what does the Holy
Spirit do he leads you into all truth
mhm now I I always consider it as a
scale so now you have a scale and you
put all your your Evolution thinking
into the one side and you put the
antithesis into the other side and let's
say you get to the point where they
balance then what are you going to do
you going go in Min or what are you
going to do so no you don't you leave
that issue alone and you say okay how's
this pan out what other evidence do we
add let's have a look at
archaeology what side of the scale is
going to go onto is it going to go onto
this side or this side it's going go and
then let's add Prof
then let add history then let's add this
and this and eventually the scale starts
doing this and even though the
scientists might have what appears to be
very logical answers if the counter
answer is equally as logical plus you
have the additional information then you
have a facts
base and even that won't convince you if
you do not have that impetus which comes
from the holy SP Spirit which tells you
you know what you're dealing with truth
how about asking and uh that's actually
what happened to me I I I did the
cardinal sin in this world evolutionary
thinking mhm one day I came to the
conclusion that I really don't know now
anymore which way it's going to was that
a weird head space to be like I'm
confusing myself now I've thought it
like this for so long and now I have
this other conflicting idea yeah I was
it was you know going crazy in my head
and I said to myself you know this is
going to drive me nuts I'm going to I'm
going to leave this stuff and I made the
the happy mistake of saying
okay if you really exist
uhoh then then reveal yourself to me
yeah I've prayed that prayer that's why
I'm here and I'll tell you that prayer
from that very day changed my life yep
the door opened all God there knocking
the whole time was waiting for the
invitation yes you know it says broad is
the way that leads to
destruction narrow is the way that leads
to eternal life and few there are that
find it I always found that very unfair
why would God hide it but the fact of
the matter is he doesn't hide it he says
seek and you will find MH so in order to
find you have to seek mhm so the
beginning of my journey as a Christian
started with that request if you exist
reveal yourself to me that's seeking mhm
and the promise is if you do that you'll
find MH to be honest people that are are
really battling in this Arena and
unwilling to seek or to to lay it on the
table I mean they select of hearing
right yes you you you you you actually
are not seeking because if you truly
were seeking you would actually want to
exhaust all these areas and see which
one is come taste test see that the Lord
is good like you would test all these
things but they don't God would never
expect you to go
against facts and knowledge in order to
embrace him the facts and the knowledge
rightly interpreted must be in harmony
with what he is telling you in fact when
you look at God in that frame that you
begin to understand and filter
everything through it blows your mind
yes and then it just continues to blow
your mind and then it blows your mind
even more like how in the world did they
have this little tiny I don't even know
what you call it I'm not a scientist and
my limited understanding of what's going
on but it has a motor and a little tail
and it swims around and it's like such a
complex little thing that is called
irreducible complexity yeah if you take
the the proton driven motor of a flugum
yeah
that's right for example the little
driving appendage to unicellular
organisms right wow that was a mouthful
yeah that mou that little structur that
engine is irreducibly complex you cannot
create it by incremental Improvement
everything has to be there it's like a a
motor MH you can't leave the Pistons out
you can't leave the crankshaft out you
can't leave any of those components out
and hope that it'll come together it has
to be complete now that motor is so
complex it has forward gears it has
reverse gears it has um low range it has
high range it can create talk to
overcome obstacles oh wow like a tractor
it can accelerate this motor and it's so
efficient there's nothing that comes
close to it and it cannot evolve it has
to come about instantaneously in that
configuration or else it doesn't work
it's called irreducible complexity and
it's a major obstacle to The
evolutionary theory so do they avoid it
don't want to talk about it well they
just add more time it must have happened
somehow
miraculously given enough time it
probably happened if you leave the
diesel engine long enough it will turn
into an
F-15 is that the idea I always I always
say you know let's compare our genes to
a book mhm that is written about
constructing whatever you're
constructing then the question is uh all
right you have the book who wrote the
book in evolution it's chance that wrote
the book because natural selection
doesn't work at the level of the genes
it only works at the level of that which
the genes have produced I can only
determine which one of you is stronger
if you're both there MH but the
blueprint of what you are is written in
a book who wrote the book chance wrote
the book or God wrote the book now the
book is so
complicated that what is the probability
of the book having been written in the
first place but even if the book is
there let's say I have the book and it
explains how to build an airplane
if I have the book how long will it take
before the airplane
appears it's not enough to have the book
it's not going to happen you have and
this is why I think it's like really
great to come at this conversation with
with I'm not a scientist but I
understand that yeah so you need the
infrastructure to convert that which is
in code into that which is a reality in
other words you need factories you need
workers you need equipment in order to
produce that which actually then exist
so if that is not subject to Evolution
but only the result thereof the physical
entity that can be tested e as to
whether it is fit or nonfit then how did
that come about even if you had the
parts even if you if you dropped off the
F-15 Parts in this
room I don't think how smart we are we
could put it together how long would
they take to assemble themselves by
chance it just couldn't
happen but it had to happen happen
because there's no Divine foot in the
door yeah that's true that's how how
improbable it is and that is why
evolution is not a theory in my opinion
it's a
faith good point so here's another
question I have for you because I I've
always wanted to ask you this question
about
CERN the uh hydrogen or no the particle
collider that's in in Switzerland there
um as as I can understand what's going
on here they're trying to break the
creation so they can understand how it's
built they want to know what it consists
of you know if you go back and sorry
what is it oh sorry yes this would be a
very good point to explain what CERN is
well CERN is an accelerator where they
use a vast underground system many
kilometers long with they accelerate
particles like protons and they Collide
them up against each other so that they
shoot apart and you can see what they
actually consist of what are they built
of so in the past you would see an atom
as consisting of a proton a neutron and
an electron and that was the the the
atomic theory everything consisted of
that that was the basic structure that
everything consisted of and the smallest
particle within that would be the
subparticle the proton for example all
right now the question then arises what
do the proton consist of yeah where'
that come from yeah where did that come
from and eventually they built the
colliders and they shoot them apart and
they discover all right these things
consist of
quarks now what's a
quark a quark is a is a subparticle that
these things consist of and quarks
always occur in in configurations of
three so there are three quarks within
let's say a proton all right but quarks
cannot exist by themselves they always
have to cons consist in a configuration
of three well isn't that the fingerprint
of God so if you shoot them apart and
you're actually in a collider in a hron
colado or whatever you shoot them apart
then you will find that each one of them
consists of three now the question is
where did the others now come from you
you shot them yes and you have a
singular quar but then it's in a
configuration of three because it cannot
exist if it's not in a configuration of
three then you get into quantum physics
and quantum physics moves into the realm
of
metaphysics you have to conceive
something which is
inexplicable and what does a quark
actually consist of well actually it
consists of
nothing so at the basis of of quantum
physics you have the hypothesis that
everything came from nothing now that's
exactly the starting point of the Bible
right God created exelia so what's the
difference between science and religion
nothing right the one is just deistic
and the other one is atheistic or one is
the theistic and the other one is
atheistic it does there is no God and
there is a God so no wonder uh people
like Einstein says I cannot wait to see
the thought of God or to see the face of
God but his concept of God was
pantheistic it wasn't a personal God
whereas the Bible introduces to you a
personal God which is totally
unacceptable to the scientific World
they will conceive of a metaphysical God
a pantheistic uh force that is in
everything of which you are part which
inherently makes you God which is
something that is negated in the Book of
Genesis because was one of the Cardinal
lies of the devil that you will be like
godh now you take the religious systems
of the world and you ask yourself well
what do they believe they all believe
that you can become God mhm but but are
these like impersonal Gods basically
that they believe in yes it's a it's a
it's a force yeah the force be with you
I mean getting into your field now now
Star Wars such a blend and mixed bag can
there be any truth when you mix all
these things together no I don't believe
so does the evolutionist not slip into
despair because at least with with with
Christianity there's hope there's hope
in Jesus but you reach to the point of
there's nothing that that's because this
is this is all to reverse Eng Jer right
so they they're trying to get to the
base so that they can recreate but then
if your base is
nothing well this is now the interesting
thing about let's say Dawkin he his
belief is once you come to the end
there's
nothing but he Embraces
um the philosophy of
Christianity as a cultural norm so there
must be some morality is there any
morality in survival of the fittest
there's no morality in survival of the
fittest so where does morality come from
with a human being so now when you
become an atheist now I was an atheist
confirmed militant
atheist doesn't mean you don't believe
anything
it means you believe almost
anything anything is possible because
you exist energy cannot be destroyed
that's a law of science it's one of the
universal laws energy or matter cannot
be destroyed it converts to energy and
energy cannot be destroyed and E equals
mc² and all of these theories so there
must be a Perpetual continuum
so it was easy for me to slip into the
esoteric
world so I was actually more
spiritualistic inclined than anything
else so let's say I was an atheistic
spiritualist because I couldn't deny
that there was a metaphysical World mhm
because there's something crazy that you
can't scientifically explain but you
know it it's there yes this is this is
another discussion on another level
no let's let's go straight to CERN and
the black holes and things that are
coming out of that I mean yes so what
are they actually finding they're
actually coming stuff coming through yes
they're looking for things that they
know must exist but don't exist how can
everything be so interconnected and yet
uh there's vast space of nothingness so
they talk about dark matter that you
cannot see or antimatter and matter does
this one consist of that one are they
mutually exclusive are they going to
destroy
themselves point of that is there's a
lot of energy in in everything and if
you can harness the energy well then you
get to the first stage which is the
atomic bomb eventually you get to the
second stage which is the hydrogen bomb
and then eventually you'll get maybe to
something which is like the Armageddon
of everything and aiming at heaven yes I
and aim it at heaven so uh that's a God
that doesn't exist I mean
I really I think these guys are are are
yeah trying to figure out how this thing
is built so that I mean I I I look at
the Devil as the layer behind all of
this right for the aliens he's trying
every angle he can possibly imagine how
do I overtake it how do I continue It
Forward how do I you know how do I just
he knows his end is is is
eminent and and he does communicate I
mean what are all these channels that
are talking to entities yeah and I've
experienced some of these things myself
and they're real you cannot you cannot
deny them you've heard the voices oh yes
I have um had personal experience in
some of these things so in this
metaphysical
world so there is something out
there uh it's divided up into good and
evil mhm but what if it's only evil and
deception but if there is evil then they
must be good because where does the
other pole come from and how do you find
it Thy word is a lamp unto my feet and a
light unto my path amen so God doesn't
do anything outside of his word because
he has to set a standard otherwise
everything can be he
sayh wow
uh are we going to start this
presentation that was awesome I mean I I
really really do think that um you know
in the end creation is going to be a a a
thing that is going to separate people
who believe right that's why I believe
Revelation 14 really talks to us like
fear God give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment's come right he's him
who made worship Him who's made those
things yeah and it's like you know that
was that was something that that that
God began to Cho choose to tell us what
happened in the very beginning stages
and then I like how you said in the Book
of Revelation we're circling back around
there the proof of that you know and
it's like even in our scientific world
it's like the proof is there yes you
know that Darin wrote his first notes on
Evolution and sent it out to other
scientists for comment in 1844 m MH I
just found that very fascinating and
interesting because that's the same year
in which spiritualism started in the
world y with the rapping in of the fox
sisters so you have
spiritualism very intricately involved
in darinmex
phenomena taking place like tables
rising from the from the floor and this
is all well documented in the literature
weird so these people were not only
scientists they were dabbling in The ult
Experience so I don't think you can just
brush it under the carpet and say that
there is no esoteric element to it yeah
and and in CERN there is that element
coming into the play as well and is what
is their deity that they have outside
it's Shiva the God of destruction right
right you could only rope so many people
into that though because you know a lot
of people are fearful of the Paranormal
so then what is the The Next Step that
the devil takes he says oh actually no
it's all a joke it's all entertainment
so come be entertained and then you have
the masses come but even in not
believing what's happening in front of
you you're still participating in that
thing and choosing a side to be on it's
the same here the bigh face started too
bah isn't isn't the bahai um a blend mhm
yeah 1844 was the same year the bigh
face started and it's an ecumenical
there
was something I think with Joseph Smith
Oh in 1844 as well I think you're right
I think he died in 1844 if I remember
right yeah same thing you were talking
about with the all the scientists or
with with Darwin happened with multiple
scientists William Crooks John loie
beard um sir Oliver
Lodge Thomas Watson all these guys yeah
huge would like to make a documentary on
that someday yeah huge spiritualists and
I'm holding out hope yeah because they
were trying to to understand how these
things in this world work so they're
blending the science and then they're
all engaged in the spiritualism
activities well Crooks when when he was
you know doing his work and he was he
had people like um um Kate Fox he
observed her and stuff in his home and
in his presidential address to the
Bristol Society in like 1898 you know he
said basically there's a entity or a
force that exists outside this
world um that that he couldn't
explain and the community ridiculed him
they derided him they said he was crazy
they said his eyesight was poor they
tried everything they could to basically
destroy his career over the thing um
they didn't do it they weren't
successful but there were multiple guys
involved in things like the ghost Guild
or the ghost club or all these
organizations where they were
investigating the Paranormal yes and
it's not only the scientific world the
entire political world runs on that
system if you go to the United Nations
you have the Temple of understanding
which is based on the writings of
blavatsky and Alisa Bailey is that the
one with the altar in the middle of the
room and when the Sun hits it at the
right spot that's another room in in the
United Nations but they have these
esoteric organizations and the bahay
have a very prominent uh position there
and they have a document where they talk
about the wronged
one and that's very fascina the one that
was kicked out unfairly the one that was
kicked out unfairly I saw that document
at the temple there at Mount Carmel M
and I just found these things they're
all
dovetailing it there is a spiritual war
behind the scenes that we cannot see but
we can
experience and sooner or later we have
to make a choice MH which ones are we
going to align our lives with the one
that is revealed in the word of God and
that is manifested in so many personal
lives I mean everybody said around this
table can probably witness to a dramatic
change in their lives as they were
confronted with these issues I don't
know where you all came from but I'm
sure you weren't born perfect Christians
to begin with so something must have
happened in your lives and we are going
to have to make a choice MH because the
scientific world the political world and
unfortunately the religious world as
well is is torn apart by these two
entities which are at war with each
other mhm and Central in this war is a
figure called Jesus
Christ that's why you will find that
that is the one that is most denigrated
most mocked most blasphemed of any
religious system in the world and when
that happens then something tells me uh
why why is there so much animosity and
so much hatred
towards this one entity and so much
embracing and acceptance of anything
else whether it be yoga or whether it be
Transcendental Meditation or whether it
be Buddhism why maybe the war centered
around this individual and that to me
says investigate and look and read and
make a decision yeah there'd be no
reason logically speaking why you would
attack that one indiv in all these
different disciplines there' be no
reason for that there would be no reason
I I'd like you to speak as a a former
college professor to students who may be
watching I think I can parallel the
students experience with Elijah Elijah
after a spiritual high after seeing the
glory of God he finds himself in the
wilderness feeling alone asking the Lord
uh to really take his life he was
depressed saying I am the only one here
I'm the only prophet of God left there's
no one else so you have a student who
may may be leaving the the the bubble so
to speak of their Christian home or
their church and they're moving to a
campus that might be very secular or
they're in a class that is teaching
evolution and they might feel very alone
in their Christianity and their
Christian beliefs maybe they haven't
gotten to that point yet that experience
where God is responding in the way that
he responded to Elijah what can you tell
that student who may be feeling alone
believing
creation well I've had a lot of years T
tertiary education and I can say that
the university for a for a believing
Christian is a very dangerous
terrain a very dangerous terrain and the
probability that you will
be uh drawn away from from your your
belief system is very great and there's
a tremendous amount of peer pressure
involved as well and if put all that
together it is a dangerous terrain for a
believer that doesn't mean that I'm
saying don't get an
education but what I am saying is if you
are a Believer fortify yourself mhm
fortify yourself in the terrain that you
are going to not all terrains are
equally aggressive if you're going into
zoology or biology you're going to be
aggressively confronted with an
atheistic mindset if you go into
something else like you know social
sciences and uh all of these then the
pressure is not so great but if you're
going into a scientific sphere and you
are a Believer then fortify yourself
make sure you understand the issue so
that you are not drawn away by
counterarguments would you be um in the
mind set to basically say look into this
a little bit and understand what these
arguments are coming so that you'll be
prepared for them when they do come yes
yes do that and if you're going to be
studying let's say medicine you're going
to be confronted with Zoological
thinking because it's part of the first
year course and the introduction and the
entire system is based on Evolution
whether you like it or not so then you
really need to be fortified so look at
the other side of the of the coin and
then uh the students always asked me how
do I answer something like this I do not
want to answer it there's no problem
answering the question according to the
theory of evolution this is how it works
and you WR exactly what the textbook
says yeah you have not compromised your
faith and you cannot be failed because
it is according to the theory of
evolution doesn't mean you have to
embrace it I took an anthrop ology class
in one of my first years in a community
college and of course it was just
non-stop this and I actually grew up
reading a lot of spirit of Prophecy
reading a lot of the Bible and and so I
kind of had this perspective and even
though myself I was beginning to exit
away from a relationship with God uh it
was still solid in my mind and I
remember taking the test and uh I
answered it honestly and and I was like
no that's not where we came from and I
got a bad
grade I went back to the teacher and I
said you know what this is this is what
I believe and and and here's why and I
think the teacher actually changed my
grade based on me answering the
questions like that I wasn't being
antagonistic I was just like that's
that's that's what I actually believe
and I think even a few of them I
answered like that according to your
book you had me read here was the answer
but this is what I actually believe and
I added some of like the Christian
belief but gave the correct answer based
on their books in your actual answer in
the exam that's not the best place to
State your case yes because when that
person is marking he's marking hundreds
of them and really he has no patience or
she has no patience with a counter
philosophy at that stage yeah if you
bring your arguments bring them earlier
yeah good and write your answer
according to what they want stating that
this is according to their Theory you
won't be compromising your faith if you
want to be really cheeky you could say
at the bottom this is what you required
of me I do not believe a word of this
and probably blow a gas you turn in two
pieces of paper the one at the top just
like the reality here's what you want me
to say I think another thing that that's
helpful if you're thinking about it I
wasn't thinking about it but I think God
in his Mercy did it for me it's he
surrounded me with people who are
like-minded and that helps a lot one of
the first people
my my family had not been going to any
church for several years by the time I
hit school and I remember the people
that first befriended me were actually
Christians and um you know and then I I
ran into a few more and and that really
helped in in my experience looking back
this may have helped I don't know I
don't know it's kind of a good and bad I
was super depressed in college and
actually didn't attend some of my
science classes
many times over and therefore got bad
grades in them at had an ecology and
evolution class I basically didn't go to
and I think I skated by with a A D um
but you know my cell biology class I had
to take a couple at times because I just
wasn't attending wasn't reading wasn't
doing
anything um but having good friends
having a good network of people to um
collaborate and share ideas with and
study the Bible is helpful
oh that was a wonderful answer fortify
yourself with information find community
and of course pray God is so patient
he's so loving so so so intentional in
everything that he does and he will
answer he will answer and provide a way
of Escape so to speak out of those
situations or eyes to see opportunity
when you can speak out and and be a
difference and I would also involve God
if for some reason you take a class
somebody starts to put thoughts in your
head that challenge your way of thinking
I think that God is such a gentleman if
you come to him and you say Lord I I I I
I have these things that now are
throwing confusion into my mind show me
the truth God is not going to ignore you
can I tell you a little story please do
I was sitting in my office and I was
contemplating all of these things and uh
I said to myself well this is this is so
contrary to everything that I stood for
believe I really need some
evidence so I went to the
library and uh I was looking at we have
at the University where I was probably
the largest evolutionary based library
in the southern hemisphere wow so I went
through those books and I looked at them
and I stood there and I said okay all
right God if you if you are in all of
this which one should I start reading
now
I was trying to find answers so I took a
book off the shelf on
Evolution and I signed it out and I was
walking out of the library and a
colleague of mine stopped me and said oh
you've taken that book there's a new
there's a new uh one that just came in
and it's still in a box at the
back a new addition I said okay he said
come let me show you so went in we went
to the boxes and opened them up and sure
enough here was the newest edition of
the same
book so for some reason I took them both
MH and I signed both of them out and I
went back to my office and I read them
together and see what was different in
the scientist yeah what is what has
changed now from the old Edition to the
new
edition and as I came to the story on
the intermediary fossils for for example
the old addition plainly said there are
no intermediary fossils to base our
conjectures on this is one of the great
gaps in the theory Etc the new one
glossed that over entirely with jargon
and so I went through and I found one
after the other where the old Edition
was still a little bit truthful and the
new edition was glossing it over with
terminology and I thought okay this is a
red flag MH and that's how I started
it's almost like the devil's Theory
right is slowly changing over time right
I mean this is why you just think that
it is a theory from the devil because
God says I am the same yesterday as I
was today and I will be tomorrow right
so so the devil's the one that's slowly
changing over time and he's the one
that's slowly changing all these things
that that God's like nope it's it's
still this particular animal packaging
the same lie over and over and then of
course I had the privilege to go into
the field to all of these uh Fossil Beds
and uh investigate for myself were they
catastrophic or were they uh deposited
over long periods of time and I just
came to the conclusion after about the
20th 30th one of them that they were all
absolutely catastrophic and therefore a
whole new paradigm opened up in my mind
wow beautiful we are definitely going to
put some links to some of your um shows
that you have created over the years
documentaries different things that um
you guys should investigate if you want
to look into this topic more um but this
we were have going to have a whole
discussion and and a whole presentation
but we got into this other discussion
which I hope you guys were definitely
blessed for and um but this this idea
that um Evolution you know what what
does it matter at this time and day and
age um I believe it's a very important
topic and if you are out there
questioning please if you got some
blessing out of this conversation and
and and the advice that you heard from
this table just look into it just
actually sit down and say Lord what is
the truth in this area because I believe
that once you start to break down
especially if you're a Christian and you
believe in evolution you know it it
begins to break down your belief system
in the word of God and that is one of
the most important things that you want
to guard that the Bible is true and it's
all profitable for Doctrine and reproof
that the whole thing can help you
understand the character of God and so
you don't want to have anybody put a
monkey wrench into your belief system
that the Bible's not really valid and
half of it's true and half of it's not
and then you become the one that that
that is the depository of what becomes
true and what becomes not there is a
line of Truth it says sanctify them by
thy truth Thy word is truth right the
Bible is how you are going to determine
what is real and what is not and I hope
that you look into Walter Vice uh
Ministry that he has especially with
Martin there's a lot of awesome topics
they have with um current events we're
going to we're going to do some shows
about that kind of a thing too so stay
tuned but thank you guys for stopping by
um give the video a thumbs like up if
you've got a family member or anybody
that's uh you know in the uh Science
World and you'd think that they would
benefit from something like this um
please share our videos they do no good
sitting in the computer um but just real
simple way you can do it send a link to
somebody and uh definitely we want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
Keith is wearing an option if someone
would like to support the ministry yeah
I have my uh lightwear t-shirt which
says Three Angels it may look like
Adidas but it's not ad is so check those
check those out at lightwear do shop so
Keith's t-shirt is actually one of the
concepts that we brought up from
Revelation 14 here's a piece of homework
for you go and find the Three Angels
message from three Revelation 14 and um
read the verse that comes about the
first Angel's message in especially in
light of this conversation if you want
to understand more about the Bible we
have a Bible School
ll. school that'll help you on that
Journey thank you guys for stopping by
we will see you next
Friday do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey and he for you
Israel make a pillar in the temple of my
God and he shall go out no more I will
ride on him the name of my
God strong in the Lord and in the
power Lord shall your strength
[Music]
shall shall
R alone but by every word that proceeds
from the mouth of God
all right I can do
this all
[Music]
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with the unique fingerprint but
we're all God's artwork wow where'd you
get
it lightwear wear your Witness
[Music]